تعال
تعال انا عايش في الخيم ه جنب الحقه
الحيوانات كل مره بسمع صوت اسد الاصوات
مزعجه بتكون مع صوت مع صوت
الصواريخ وفي الحديقه كل اطفال فو 30
عائله حتنا كثير كثير صرنا عايشين جنب
الحيوانات نسمع زئير الاسد يعني ندوش كثير
كثير من الحيوانات فنقدر نعيش هنا
ابدا زي ما انتم شايفين في الصوره يعني
سبناهم في البيت وفي الحديقه نفسها حولنا
يعني بعض الاقفاص فيها الطيور فضينا مثلا
بعد الفاس او عملنا لهم
خيام هذ يمكن النازحه الرابعه او الخامسه
من حي الشجا لحد وصلنا رف اول حاجه
انتقلنا الى غرب غزه وبعد غرب غزه اجينا
لوسط غزه اجينا على القراره وبعد القراره
توجهنا
ل مدرسه ابن خلدون للهواء نا ساكنين في
السياره زي ما انت شايف يعني هي السياره
اللي احنا ساكنين فيها لانه المدرسه
مقتصده وم لانا بني ادمين وم لانا عرايش
والصوف مالانا كل مساحه السياره مربع لا
يتعدى 30 متر او 40 متر يعني بدك تضرب
مترين ونص في 8 متر قديش اضربهم لحالك
فيهم 30 ست سبع عيال عايشين 30 نفر في قلب
مساحه 40 متر حاطين
حرام البنات جوا
واحنا لبرا وعاملين طوابق يعني شي بنام
فوق ششي بنام
تحت بسبب انه الدمار اللي حل في الشجاعيه
وبسبب انه بيوتنا طبعا الثلاثه راحت سنضطر
انه هذه الخيمه برضه نعيش فيها في غزه لما
نرجع الشجاعيه ان شاء الله ومع انهم حتى
في الانرو وفي الوكاله بيجوا يشرفوا على
ماكن الاواء تمام شوفوا ويشوفوا الحال
اللي فيها وك الامور عاديه والكل اعتاد
على هذا المنظر والكل اعتاد انه يشاهد
الفلسطيني بهذه
الصوره البيت يعني رغم ان احنا مكسوف
وهينا قاعدين فيه وين بدنا نروح يعني
بنصبر حالنا قاعدين في خيمه هالقد احنا
والصغار
وكلنا هذا عاملين الخيمه وعايشين عليها هذ
ست عائلات ساكنين فيها بقعد فيها النسوان
والاطفال ناموا زلام احنا بدبر حالنا
برا
ثاني يوم ثالث يوم خلصنا دفن الشهداء
تبعنا وخلصنا كل حاجه جبنا الخيم ونصبنا
وضلينا قاعدين وسكنا عليك وبنينا الفرون
وبنينا كل حاجه ونعيش لما الله
يفرجها كان ح النظاف واليهود صفوها و
حملنا فوق الدار خامه وهنا بقعد وهنا
بناكل وهنا
بنشرب اشتقت لمدرسته اشتقت لالعاب
ما لقيناش يا بني فيش مكان تحط ارجلك في
البلد اولادنا هذا هم مرمين حتى لو فوق
فوق الركام بدنا نعيش ايش بدنا نعمل مش
طالع بدينا يعني اكثر
منه اقل عريش بقول لك بف شيكل من وين نجيب
الفات شواكل احنا انا والله يعني بقيت
ساكن في الرات وسبنا دورنا وسبنا العابنا
وسبنا اصحابنا وهينا هنا زي ما انت شايف
على الردم ويعني وقت ايش بدنا نخلص من
هالحال هذا ونرجع لاصحابنا لاحبابنا نرجع
عدونا سالمين
غالين